whether you love it hate it I've never
thought about it chances are some nanny
wants to ban it presenting the nanny of
the month runners-up in an out Burgers
hometown Baldwin Park California which
just might ban new drive-throughs it all
boils down to thongs at the beach the
mayor of teary Beach North Carolina for
leading a ban on cheeky Beach where I
think on some people that would be great
but on me that would be but there can be
only one nanny of the month and this
time it's US Attorney's Stephanie Rose
for suggesting that the federal
government can tell you what kinds of
food you're allowed to eat it's about
these animals they're endangered okay we
know we can't ship everything into our
pie holes but when Rose declared that
Americans do not have a fundamental
right to obtain any food they wish she
referred not to Komodo dragons but to
raw milk she was defending the feds ban
on interstate sales suspected of selling
raw milk on the Internet and many states
simply outlaw the white stuff entirely
check back next month for more examples
of busybodies minding your own business
[Music]